[Musik]
herzlich willkommen hier heute zu einem
neuen druck auf meinen kanal meine damen
und herren im heutigen blog werden
wer frieden gibt es bereits den titel
eingewendet freunde ich reagiere heute
mal wieder auf rich kids
ich bin nur reich an bilden ich habe auf
meinem kanal schon mal auf online
der blaue ball ich hoffe ihnen kann er
schon mal auch für komische rich kids
von instagram mietvertrag er geht jedoch
reagiere ich heute auf rich kids von
stage at wie unterscheiden sich nicht
krass aber ich habe wieder einige echt
verstörende bilder gefunden bevor das
ganze allerdings tun werde meine damen
und herren machen wir uns erst mal
perfekt leute wir planen ja gerade die
zweite luca pizza und heute sind die
ersten exemplare angekommen
ihr seht aber noch nicht was eventuell
der belag sein könnte also nachher heute
abend im flop werden wir dann mal eine
pizza probieren und ja mein name ist
luca hackl wird ein weiterer fun fact
freunde ich habe gerade diesen stift
wieder gefunden und es ist kein normaler
stift dieser stift ist nämlich ein stück
stift den habe ich mir damals mal in
meiner uni zeit noch bestellt das
problem war nur also man kann ihn ganz
leicht herausziehen in der klausuren
kann eine menge heraus schreiben
allerdings wenn die wieder einfangen
will macht ja und es ist ein bisschen zu
laut wie passen aber wirklich eine menge
informationen darauf also leute falls
ihr noch zur schule geht gerade abi
machte das uni geht es diesen hinweis
habt ihr nicht von mir bekommen
ich weiß ich wollte einfach so dass ich
jetzt auf dieser rich kids von snapshot
er reagiere allerdings habe ich heute
diese postgasse bei mir im briefkasten
gefunden und diese postkarte stammt von
einer guten freundin von mir namens
carola also mal schauen was sie uns so
nettes geschrieben hallo bin saufen
hier kann man verfüge postkarte
verschicken ich hasse euch schießen
düsseldorfer köln dankeschön für deine
netten postkarte carola
püriert reagiere ich endlich auf
komische vertritt
das hier ist das erste foto was ich
heraus gesucht habe von rich kids auf
snapshot freunde innovativer king wird
mal klick steht darunter der typ trägt
eine frau habe keine ahnung von uhren
auf jeden fall irgendwie teure uhr und
der andere typ hält in der hand
irgendwie 400 500 euro in bar
ihr seid die mit den dicksten klöden war
das hier ist das zweite foto sunparks to
close the bentley sehen wir da warum
seid ihr so unter menschen entsteht ein
bentley neben noch einen bentley neben
einem auch teurem auto warum stellt man
sich dann davor und fotografiert diese
drei karren und vor allem mit dem
untertitel biss haben und park zu close
to the bentley
da hat niemand zu nada neben geparkt das
hier ist wahrscheinlich jetzt gerade an
einer privatschule oder so und alle
kinder werden abgeholt und wir sehen da
vorne eigentlich nur suvs von range
rover die person selber sitzt in einem
wir sehen auf dem parkplatz einen range
rover parken und im rückspiegel sieht
man auch einen range rover wow just
private school fehlt nummer vier ist das
hier der die augen liga das ist vor
story house also unser team hat sich
einfach nur als haus einst gekauft mit
nur vier stockwerken und dieser hund ist
auch so ein typischer reichen hund
überhaupt nichts gegen hunde ich will da
gar nicht mit rein sind aber sonne
weißer pudel kommen
das ist richtig richtig klischee einfach
ready to worry about screen peking also
auf deutsche war selbst mein dad will
nicht dass irgendwie meine kamera frei
ist und dass leute mich vielleicht
ausspionieren können und deswegen klebt
der einfache unmengen an dollars da
drauf und keine normalen dollar scheine
wie irgendwie ein dollarschein und dann
irgendwie zehn stück davon oder
irgendwie so und da ist das ding
abgeklärt 100 dollar scheine
cool du bist jemand mit dem ich nie
kontakt haben möchte hier wieder ein
bild von einer privatschule untertitel
ist tut myspace private school props
also probleme wenn auf einer privaten
schule bist die person hat einfach
keinen parkplatz genommen und das mit
einem lamborghini cool wenn du auf
meinem parkplatz parken solltest werde
ich ihn mit einem golfschläger alles
zusammentreten
soll ich dann mit einem golfschläger
treten ich habe gar nicht gesagt warum
ich gegangen bin einem leute
unterschätzen ist angekommen also wir
essen das jetzt und wir haben oft genug
und jonas und jetzt geht es weiter mit
dem video meiner reaktion auf die bis
jetzt hier sehen wir jemanden der an
seinem riesigen grundstück steht und der
untertitel ist jeffrey wrecking becker
skate also jeffrey macht gerade hier die
den wasserfall sauber und ja da sieht
man einfach dass solche menschen die so
ist ihre story hauen einfach so hart
herablassend sich über andere leute und
vielleicht in einer schicht unter ihnen
stehende leute so krass lustig darüber
machen das ist doch einfach nur
unsympathisch also ich finde alle leute
sollen alle güter besitzen die sie
besitzen wollen und die reichsten leute
sollen sie reich sein wie sie wollen und
können sich kaufen was sie wollen aber
solange sie damit angeben ist es einfach
nur ekelhaft ich bin ganz ehrlich zu
euch freunde ich verdiene mit youtube
auch echt ok es geld eigentlich für
dafür dass ich hier so eine scheiße
mache allerdings bin ich jetzt niemand
der jeden tag eine story hat hey schaut
mal ich in meinem land oder schaut mal
hier ich in meinem zehn millionen dollar
würdet ihr euch doch auch einfach denken
hey das ist schön dass du das hast du
bist juckt uns einfach nicht aber gut
freude wir machen weiter mit dem
nächsten foto und zwar dass hier tritt
starting something unter den ich mir
einfach nur so dass kein euro verkauft
sich zwei iphone 5 s und zwei macbooks
aber das muss man halt immer dazu sagen
also bei diesen ganzen rich kids snap
chat instagram bildern da ist eine menge
einfach wirklich fake von und die wollen
einfach nur von diesen seiten irgendwie
gefeatured werden poppt er
wahrscheinlich arbeit ist so einem
weinladen hausparty das finde ich
ehrlich gesagt gar nicht mal so schlimm
weil ich finde wenn das jetzt irgendwie
hochzeit ist oder irgendwie so oder
irgend eine geile party weil jemand ein
unternehmen weil wir das einfach da
sieht man dass die person sich gedanken
gemacht hat
natürlich stehen relativ teure getränke
wahrscheinlich aber ich meine das gehört
zu einer party und partys manier
investition also das finde ich ehrlich
gesagt nicht so schlimm an
alle ökonomen da draußen die party ist
natürlich keine investition wie jetzt
eine immobilie oder ein oldtimer oder
nur dann werd wertpapier oder sowas aber
man investiert in kontakte und ich finde
das geht gerade auf partys knüpft man so
viele kontakte und das ist echt wichtig
fürs leben live at weiß bei luca wir
machen weiter pretty average ich
verstehe solche leute mich mein okay
wenn man jetzt irgendwie im club sondern
willen tisch haben weil man einfach ab
und zu mal sitzen möchte und das soll
ein bisschen entspannter sein möchte
auch ein bisschen was trinken da kauft
man sich vielleicht mal eine flasche in
die anhalt so 200 euro kostet er
schmeißt man dann wenn man es zum
fünften zusammen da zahlt jeder 40 euro
das geht echt klar für so ein partyabend
so eine flasche enthält aber locker drei
bis fünf liter champagner oder wodka
oder keine ahnung was das heißt sie
kostet die sie vierstellig
und da denke ich mir einfach für den
preiskrieg den normale
champagnerflaschen da kriegt ihr
jahresvorrat für zehn jahre building
killer apps die das foto wurde auch auf
einer der ganz vielen rip it seiten
hochgeladen und ich habe es einfach mal
mit reingenommen weil ich hier selber
gerade dabei bin mit zwei freunden eine
app zu entwickeln also ein spiel für das
iphone und das habe ich schon in
mehreren blogs bisher gesagt und viele
leute fragen mich auch immerhin luca wie
sie zeit nicht auf der edw ankommt die
raus wir sind dabei die wollen halt
einfach nicht dass das so das akkurat
spiel wird und dann ist einfach ins
unternehmen entwickelt uns dass ein paar
tagen das ist online und dann lässt sich
sicher runter und läuft es dann am tag
wieder sondern es soll echt cool werden
und das ding ist halt auch so ein
bisschen wir haben uns schon angebote
eingeholt von entwicklerstudios aus
hamburg und berlin aber es war alles so
frank teuer und es ist uns real-tor
keine 60.000 euro wert ein spiel
entwickeln zu lassen deswegen gehen wir
das ganze jetzt selbst an freunde ihr
werdet auf jeden fall updates erhalten
die nächsten blogs irgendwann aber jetzt
machen wir weiter mit dem nächsten rich
kids nett und zwar diesem hier des fuel
hedging also diese ganzen fund scheine
die alle 20 und beinhalten sind obwohl
dies die beste lösung gegen die
kopfschmerzen
von dieser person
als gäste des networking ich verstehe
diese leute nicht so cool
auch dieser snap einfach rennrad
optisches und einfach dollar scheine da
reingesteckt so geil
ihr habt bargeld in der hand cool family
reunion today und deswegen liegt in
diesem lambo auch noch vorne das
preisschild drin das letzte rich kids
auf snapshot foto was sich draußen sucht
hat meine damen und herren es etwas wo
ich wirklich lachen musste und zwar
nimmt diese person das ganze so ein
bisschen hoch und zwar das here on the
way to steal your girl und er hat keine
rolex um aber ein bild von der rolex und
er fährt auch kein ferrari sondern hält
nur sein ipad wo ein lenkrad von einem
ferrari abgebildet ist da habe ich auf
jeden fall gelohnt
an der stelle würde ich diese rich kids
auf snap check steht allerdings auch
band meine damen und herren der block
geht natürlich weiter und zwar jetzt
weil wir gehen jetzt ins gymi olaf bock
auf chemo hier hast du bock auf stimmt
ja motiviert von idiotischen sachen wie
läuft sie mit dem training wieder eine
kamera deren das training hat mich ein
bisschen zerstört allerdings gehen wir
jetzt noch duschen freunde deswegen will
ich den blog dass er jetzt auch
eigentlich ist das gar nicht cool wenn
ich meine reaktion auf diese komischen
marriage kid s next gefallen hat das
gerne mal ein like das schleppen die
kommentare seit ihr cool oder dumm ja
würde mich echt interessieren
ciao
[Musik]